يأخذ الجار الذي يساعد الجار أشكالًا عديدة ،
لذا أترك كيغالي وأتوجه إلى
الريف
للحصول على تفسير غير عادي
آه ، متحف قصر الملك
[موسيقى]
يمكنني سماع الأبقار التي لا يمكن أن تكون بعيدة
آه ، وهنا الرجل الذي سيريني
أنا أسمع  الأبقار ،
لذا يرجى التوقف عند هذا الحد إذا كنت
ترتدي زيًا مثل هذا لا يمكنك زيارته في
yambo ،
لذا تأكد من
ارتداء الملابس التقليدية ثم نزور
yambo معًا.
الأبقار هذا أفضل ، أفضل إدوارد
هو شاعر ووزير ثقافي سوف
يشرح
لك ، هل يمكنك لمسهم ، فهم يستمتعون به ، لا
تقلق
أنهم ودودون ويحترمونك
بسبب التقاليد
السائدة في أنيامبو التي تتمتع بمكانة ملكية في
رواندا
[تصفيق  ]
أنا لا أمزح أن هذه الأبقار مدللة مغنية
ومزينة ، أنا فقط أنتظر أن
أتعافى من أحد هذه الأشياء ، نعم ،
لكنها لطيفة للغاية
نرفع أيدينا
هكذا ، وكأنها في قرن يامبو إنها  من السهل على
ما يبدو إعطاء بقرة لشخص ما
كهدية
هو علامة على الاحترام الكبير إذا كنت تريد
أن تتمنى ثروة شخص ما ،
فأنت تمنحه بقرة ، وإذا أعطيتك
بقرة ،
يبدو الأمر كما لو أننا نحرق
صداقتنا ، فلا يمكنك خيانة شخص
قدم  أنت بقرة
في هذا المجتمع ، من الأساسي جدًا
أن يكون لديهم كلمة لذلك.
عندما يكون للبقرة عجل ، فأنت
تعطيه لجارك الذي ليس لديه
في اليامبو ويثير غرينكا ألف
سؤال ماذا لو لم يكن لديك
حديقة أو لم يكن لديك حقل
ماذا لو كنت لا تريد؟
لن يقول أحد إنه لا يمتلك سيارة ، فأنت
تعلم
أن الأمر مثلك عندما تقول إنك لا
تريد المال أو لا تريده حيث إذا
أدركت أنني أكون عمليًا ولكن
بطريقة خاطئة
هذا عن التطبيق العملي للأمة
الجار مساعدة الجار لا أحد
التخلي عن ال  هذه الأبقار على الرغم من
أنها بمثابة كريم دي لا كريم إذا
كنت
ستعقد في قصر الملك إعادة
بناء مسكن من الأيام التي
حكم فيها الملوك رواندا
الآن حان دوري لتكريم في يامبو
هناك مقولة لا يمكنك
ليس لديك عدو مع شخص ما شربت
الحليب معه أو شيء
ما عندما تشارك الحليب ، فهذه علامة حقيقية
على الصداقة ، حسنًا ، فلدينا أي
حليب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عندما تشرب الحليب ، نعم ،
عليك إنهاء  الجزء الخاص بك
الكل في واحد لماذا هي ثقافة
تصنعها ، لا
هذا خطأ
[موسيقى]
أنت تشرب الحليب بطريقة غير لائقة
وخاطئ بشكل صحيح مع
مجتمع المصالحة هذا الذي
يلعب دوره التقليدي بطريقة جديدة تمامًا ،
نعم أنت كذلك  جميل